un colis pour un client l'a pas son
numéro est jaloux dans la maison
regarder ce que je vois là et je serai
là c'est une énigme la folie vu les
films ou quoi c'est comment en mai
dernier j'ai suivi cydia dans son
quotidien de chauffeurs les voies pour
la poste alors je l'avais découvert sur
tik tok voulais raconter toutes ces
galères maison du 35è la boîte aux
lettres et l 39 et à sa boîte aux
lettres
là est la beauté du 37 mais y'a pas la
maison ya qu une grille la milice la
passion c'est la scène aujourd'hui s'est
fait un nom sur les réseaux sociaux et
ce soir il va enfin monter sur scène et
rencontrer son public
j'ai livré aussi voyante et a notamment
vu mais c'est cool et où le temps s'est
dit je vais te faire une prédiction
gratuit qui a été choisi l'écouté quand
même c'est pas grave
amadio écoute tu atterris c'est que t'as
même pas tomber enceinte lumina comment
va l'équipe des brutes ça va nickel
ça se passe apparemment let's go là il
est 15 heures c'est ça je suis retourné
à la journée s'est livré à de qualité
supérieure les soirs des humoristes on
est allé voir ces artistes de qualité
supérieure raconte beaucoup de nos
livreurs je racontais c'est un peu des
choses que j'ai vécues mais oui il ya
beaucoup de livraison et la maintenance
maintenant qu'ils me reconnaissent
thomas ils font un peu plus d'attention
mais attendu que conway
je veux revoir attention tu me désespère
tu vas y avait un côté sans voir comme
ça tu vois mais il ya des dagues rien
n'a plus le temps césar est passé ça me
donne de l'inspiration vrais gens
désirent tant mieux mon but web en fait
moi c'est surtout web adam vivre quoi
c'est vraiment une passion que j'aime
beaucoup c'est
ça me permet aussi de me libérer de
m'exprimer sur des choses que des fois
j'arrive pas forcément à dire dans la
vraie vie
ouais c'est menottes ses menottes
en tant que médecin de vue là c'est là
que je prescris mes ordonnances que je
joue sur scène la part de la villette
c'est ici enfin je me suis non lecture
au petit fait que j'ai la balle dans la
tête
et après bien souvent il ya de
l'improvisation souvent de fatma temps
après tout dépend aussi des réactions du
public des fois mais en principe il ya
beaucoup d'impro aussi tu as fait un bon
20 minutes j'ai justement lecture quoi
la lecture comme ça sans les rires les
compagnies quoi voir espérant qu'il en
est évidemment
[Applaudissements]
ça avance aaron soir ça vaut bien la
peine ça fait plaisir d'être un beau de
ici kuzunda dessus dans des lieux assez
bizarre ou d'allergie derrière nous
c'est compliqué quand le mec qui passe
devant et tous ses rouages eu mon bac
mais j'ai pas lâcher d'affaires en 22
ans pas faire je suis parti on ne parle
plus d'eux du coup aujourd'hui je suis
chauffeur livreur il livrait aussi
voyante et a notamment jeu vidéo mais
c'est collé tout le temps s'est dit je
vais te faire une prédiction gratuite y
jeter s'est choisi il écoutait quand
même c'est pas grave
amadio écoute ce qui va t'arriver c'est
que t'as même pas tomber enceinte un
débit et à une bonne nouvelle franchise
et puis à sectionner je n'ai pas de mots
plus rien
une arnaque cette mesure est toutefois
aussi j'ai livré un client et c'est en
plein hiver talus dg tout ça est où
maintenant j'arrive devant chez lui je
sens pour le prévenir que j'arrive
maintenant lui sors moi je monte dans
mon camion pour prendre son colis c'est
pas en descendant du canonge thomas ne
l'était pas il était juste ont pesé je
suis tombé en cas d'alternance gino
soles le clip est intelligent a dit je
n'ai rien de cassé hors la loi je me
relie père vito match n'était pas
évident parce que comme il est fragile
[Applaudissements]
ouais c'est si doux mais la qualité est
rien voilà exactement